let me get to Sam amick he's the senior
NBA national writer for the athletic Sam
thanks for joining us we were taking a
survey here in the man cave are you
going to be a bubble guy or not
and I said let's see I said no Polly is
Sam a bubble guy fritzy I think he's
going to the bubble bubble guy see yeah
I'm gonna say no McLovin no bubble no
bubble Pauly I say TBD because he
doesn't know all the details of the
moment okay he's going bubble okay Sam
Dan gentleman appreciates you first of
all it's surreal that we're talking
about bubbles and this is our media life
I don't know yet honestly after this
interview later today I'll be talking to
my company about it as you know it's
about 10 people on the inside and it is
culture shock and every sense of the
term so we shall see but man it's
surreal that this is what we're what
we're looking at who would be the last
member of the media that you would want
to be bunking with Chris Mannix made it
made it easy for me
oh my god Mannix would be fun but that's
the thing you're not gonna have fun
you're not going to have the high jinks
that come with our industry and and the
stress relief that comes after the games
I mean from players to staff to media
members it's gonna be something we've
never seen before well we're trying to
figure this out and I know we all have
the best intentions here what is the
biggest concern you have is we get ready
to open up these NBA camps for me it's
it's it's weird because you take your
media hat off and and my focus is just
as a human and as a person it's just the
idea that you get in there and they have
you know 95% ish and this is my
unofficial math of the the risk
contained but they're getting tested
once a day and so what I worry about is
that because you have Disney employees
still coming and going Disney employees
not being tested it's you know and I've
had GM's tell me this it's not a bubble
in the definition of the bubble and the
term you know it's it's something else
it's a campus as they've called it and
there is risk there
and it only takes one case and next
thing you know that player gets tested
in the morning let's say he's positive I
mean you know but I'm sorry negative
then he gets it later in the day and he
infects a whole bunch of folks before
the next day's test you're not getting
tested every hour so there is risk here
I just hope they can pull this thing off
what's happening with a second site here
that everybody's gonna be in Orlando but
is there a push who's complaining about
maybe having a second site second city
so the a-teams
not going to Orlando want to find a way
for their guys to not sit on their
couches for six seven months and the
phrase you hear them say and I'm talking
mainly GM's of those teams and to be
honest the one that I think they know
might potentially compel the league to
do something for them it's competitive
disadvantage and I'm talking big picture
the idea that you have all these young
prospects I think that's the real focus
the old guys can find their way they
want to develop a talent and not have
guys go into twenty twenty-one you know
with what their skills going in the
wrong direction and so it seems like the
support is almost universal the Warriors
didn't see him interested earlier on but
now I'm hearing that they it would have
at least some interest and like you said
you know I'm gonna leave in you're
talking about another campus another
site and the league I know on a call
last week mentioned Vegas they mentioned
Houston has two out of four
possibilities but then you also have a
bunch of these teams honestly I think
probably more than half that would like
to host this thing the t-wolves the Cavs
the Pistons you know a lot of teams are
trying to figure something out here when
do the the NBA players report July 9 is
when it starts July 9 to 11 is the kind
of the travel dates and then they start
bouncing balls from there I know that
the Commissioner has hinted I had a TV
executive tell me that you're gonna see
some things that you've never seen
attached to the NBA as far as dressing
up those games now he didn't go into the
details but I don't know if we're seeing
Disney animation characters and like
Creighton he said think crazy and then
work your way back
what are you here about of these games
gonna look so Adam silver pulled that
curtain back a little bit on his Friday
call and honestly I think it was an
hour-long call there was a lot to dig
into and I think for the most part this
topic got you know kind of pushed to the
side but he mentioned one thing that I
thought was wild was that fans obviously
who will not be in attendance there will
be no fans but you could be watching the
game and have you know the NBA app open
on your phone and essentially there
would be a button that would constitute
a clap or a tear and if you had if you
had on how it works they somehow
quantify you know which team is getting
more of those claps at that certain time
and then in the arena you would have
lights and colors of that team
represented where the players could look
up and you know if the pelicans see a
blue then you know they know their fans
are I've got their back and then you're
gonna have piping crowd noise in some
capacity virtual halftime shows there's
something they're veterans so I mean
they're gonna get creative and we'll see
if any of it actually little and if by
chance the pelicans meet up with the
Lakers yeah that matchup no I'm not
gonna say that's on purpose but I know
that we would love to have Zion in there
so I I'm not I wouldn't go that far Sam
but just can the pelicans give the
Lakers a difficult series I probably not
I don't think I mean they look pretty
good
you know heading into the break I I
think they're probably frustrated I mean
everybody frustrated but in terms of if
you just focus on the hoops and which
teams had all of their momentum brought
to a halt the pelicans are on that short
list now the Lakers lose Avery Bradley
that's a significant loss you know looks
like they're you know likely gonna add
JR Smith and so we'll see where that
goes the Dwight Howard factor you know
it's white gonna be there but no the
Lakers are I mean they're a top three
team obviously they're elite and Zions
been so much fun to watch and they've
had some really good moments but I mean
to me that's a Lakers in five no more
than six five series I know that you
follow
ball because he of course helped invent
basketball but I saw where he was
tweeting out about his son mmm Golden
State would not be a good place for his
son to go to if he's drafted number one
overall sure it
we're just golden state figure in all of
this that are they gonna draft somebody
or would they trade that pick I think
they would definitely trade it not to
say they will but I mean in terms of the
possibility being there for a team at
that spot you know nine times out of ten
you know it's gonna be a rebuilding team
that is looking to grab a guy like
lobello and just start to make in part
of their core the Warriors are in such a
different place and honestly I don't
blame levar at all for not wanting
lamella to land there they're just they
are trying to continue the dynasty I
know that in the media and and I'm not
even being guilty of it and I am on the
side that says you know that dynasty
came to an end now they can still be a
very very good team but in their minds
like this story ain't over and so that
means that you know a number one pick
however good he might be is going to
take a number of years to get going Zion
is an exception and we even saw on the
health front how it took him a minute to
get going so you know when you've got
that the roster they have and your levar
you're looking at that saying how is he
going to get run right away how is he
going to get time and the kind of
development that he needs you know
there's only one ball the old adage and
I think that applies there does the
situation in Orlando favor any team I
mean the ones that to me are in a good
spot the Clippers for one my
understanding is they had zero of the 16
positive coronavirus tests going into
the last week's testing that's
significant they also seem to have been
very diligent about how focused they
were during the downtime Doc Rivers had
coined a phrase winning the weight he
wanted his team to win the weight and to
that just obviously means stay on top of
your fitness stay on top of your mental
health take care of yourself and be
ready to you know lessen that curve in
that timeline
it's going to happen for everybody when
you hit mid July so they come to
mine in Kauai in general is a crazy
person in terms of being focused on his
craft and I think that's gonna serve
them well you know the Blazers come to
mind too they get use of Newark inch
back and Zach Collins and Damian Lillard
just always has to be talked about
on that short list of guys who is gonna
meet the moment and and maybe you know
be kind of an upset specialist here give
me the sneaky team well I mean I kind of
spoiled the answer on that one I think
Portland is a good one
because for one I mean it's gonna be
crazy to see how the 89 situation goes
in the West now Memphis obviously is
about three and a half in front of the
pack
you got three teams coming on strong
behind them but if Portland can get in
there I can see them doing it the
pelicans we kind of talked about you
know that's a squad that did talent-wise
and they were finding their way could do
something I don't really see any great
you know teams in the east with that
identity I mean if Brooklyn had
magically gotten Kyrie Irving right back
then that's all we would be talking
about right now but for the most part I
mean if you're talking big picture
Conference Finals finals to me it's it's
it's the Milwaukee Lakers clippers
triumvirate and then kind of everybody
else after that finish this sentence if
the Lakers don't make the NBA Finals
then
LeBron's my focus would probably be
LeBron LeBron's legacy which is
incredible will remain for the most part
where it is and he'll try again next
year but it's been interesting for me
Dan covering leagues since roughly
around 2005 covering LeBron for most of
his career you then I've never covered
an athlete of this stature at this stage
of his career and this pandemic happened
and I truly do think that you know the
NBA and I'm saying this is a very small
part that as they considered what to do
here I think Adam silver cares about
LeBron I think he's a very player
friendly coach in general and I think
that they gave great thought to the fact
that him losing this opportunity is the
kind of thing that that other greats
didn't have to face and they didn't want
that to happen and don't get the wrong
idea I'm not saying this is the driving
force behind Orlando but I think it
matters and so
if they weren't if he wasn't able to
capitalize on that you know at least he
would have had the chance but but in
terms of his legacy you know it would be
two years in LA and and for his
standards still nothing to show for it
in terms of what he's aiming for so it's
not the battering ram by the
commissioner but it's factored in if the
if LeBron was in Cleveland not LA cuz la
is gonna bring people to the screen they
get to the finals yeah we're gonna watch
no matter what Hawaii is not gonna bring
that nobody really brings that like
LeBron but if if LeBron was on a team
that was not a great team right now do
you think that this there would still be
this push by the commissioner that we're
gonna make this happen in Orlando I mean
only Adam knows you know where his mind
was at and to be respectful to him I
mean health I do believe was front and
center all the way through but you know
these are real relationships these are
real legacies and you're talking about
you know the point you're making is
astute because if he was still in
Cleveland and it was a continuation of
that cab narrative and even if they were
an elite team I think there would be
this sense that okay we have seen that
before and they did you know deliver the
city's first NBA championship this is a
new thing where you can try to honor his
legacy but also oh by the way you know
put a bunch of money in your pocket
because they are a revenue driver and
that's the other thing here I feel like
I've been on this mountaintop preaching
about how throughout this whole process
in the media it's okay to be adults
about it and consistently remind people
that yes this is about money you know
it's it is this is it's why they're here
it's 900 million dollars roughly in
national TV revenue that they would have
lost if they didn't pull off the
playoffs you know and that's only one
piece of their pie and as one GM had
told me in a recent piece I wrote the
back end of this if they don't have the
playoffs for the league at large could
have a ripple effect for five to ten
years and not just the players and the
coaches who I think it's easy to say
well they'll be fine I'm talking that
regular folks within all these
organizations layoffs
in mass potentially if this league kept
bleeding money and that certainly is a
major major factor here probably the
number one fact Sam great to talk to you
if you go into the bubble good luck
little say our prayers thank you death
appreciate you yeah Sam Amick he just
won't take us up on changing his name to
sam amic like we keep we keep trying it
he could go by one name he could be a
one name writer Samak maybe like staying
of the NBA just won't take me up on it
senior NBA national writer for the
athletic thank you Sam